it's sort of the world of laughing which
is live-action roleplay just gone awry
which is summoned a succubus from hell
all right
my character sort of loses the love of
his life she he finds out that she's
been cheating on him and his housemates
who you know played by Steve Zahn and
Peter Dinklage they kind of kidnapped me
and they're very much into this game and
I wake up and I'm in the middle of this
slapping game so I sort of go along with
it just to keep them happy and suddenly
these crazy crazy things start happening
of killer shrooms I mean we got the guys
from spectrum motion who do a lot of
gmos work it's so much more believable
than the CGI stuff you didn't have to
fake the acting it's not like I'm acting
against a green-screen they were there
the two sides are there and people are
dying and but they're dying is such a
loose term because at first you know
it's just a point system and you fall
down on the ground so when my character
gets wind of people from his camp that
are dying he originally doesn't take it
that serious is that okay well he
obviously got hit by a foam sword so
what but when they start seeing trails
of blood
you know things start getting very very
serious well the great thing is that
Hall H is obviously what you would hope
for for a film I mean you've got Studios
that they try and buy lot time in that
whereas Pama can have seen the trailer
for hours and said we want to give you
that so that already was a nice vote of
confidence from them the the fans at
comic-con is so not just well researched
but just very respectable so they'll
come up and they'll sort of tell you
different things about your character
maybe a quote or two and take a photo
and leave it's really kind of pleasant
it's a nice ego boost I guess if you're
having a bad day as an actor
come here and you'll leave a happy man
or woman